more reaction to Trump's criticism of
the w-h-o let's go to Katrina you in
Beijing Katrina what have we been
hearing from Beijing well China and the
US have been engaging in a bit of war of
words regarding the corona virus
pandemic and Beijing really sees that
Washington in their opinion is trying to
simply shift the blame when it comes to
the criticism of the World Health
Organization that's been very much
echoed in state media reports today a
lot of headlines for example here we've
got an editorial from the Global Times
which is a state media newspaper very
much attacking Trump in his decision to
withdraw funding from the WTO saying
that it is a move against humanity and
it sets a horrible precedent at a time
when the world really should be rallying
behind the agency it also says that
Trump really is using this as some sort
of political ammunition to try to
bolster his chances of re-election as
well and conversely state media are
painting China as the opposite kind of
being very active and taking a kind of
leadership role in this global fight
against the pandemic reminding the
public that China donated 20 million
dollars to the agency in March and has
since then sent plane loads of medical
supplies testing kits and other funds to
more than 80 countries since then
Katrina
there's been a lot of speculation as we
all know about China's transparency
during this process given the fact that
you are there are you getting a sense of
how people in China are reacting to
those allegations that there should have
been more transparency and there wasn't
definitely I think people here genuinely
believe that there is a downward trend
in infections just evidenced by the
government's open opening up of China
people are going back to work the
economy is getting started again but as
to whether these numbers that we have
these official figures are accurate
there are a lot of questions China
maintains that there have only been
about 82,000 cases of carbon 19 across
the country and that's much less in
terms of numbers when you compare it to
the US or many European countries and
that has raised eyebrows and in addition
to that The Associated Press has come
out saying that China's National Health
Commission actually warned China's
leaders about the severity of this
outbreak as early as January 14 saying
that this could really develop into I
quote a major public event and it's the
more severe challenge they face since
SARS in 2003 but it was only six days
later that the Communist Party announced
to China and to the world that there was
this outbreak and that it was very
severe so questions are being asked as
to why the government was not so
forthcoming with that information and on
top of that we know at a more local
level in Wuhan heed who Bay Province the
original epicenter of the outbreak
doctors who tried to sound the alarm
about this outbreak as early as the end
of December or indeed silenced or
punished for doing so and because of
this kind of patchy track record there
are a lot of questions now as to whether
the Chinese government are continuing to
really be transparent when it comes to
the scale of the outbreak here in China
a Katrina you live for us in Beijing
thank you very much indeed while also
joining us from Beijing is ina Tannen
he's an advisor to the Chinese
government on economic and development
issues and he's joining us now thank you
very much indeed for your time as always
ina let me ask you first do you think
that China regards this as solely an
issue between the US and China with
regard to the w-h-o or is it about wider
issues yes I mean obviously as I said
before China believes that Trump is
trying to use this as a political issue
for his campaign to say that there's
some sort of conspiracy between the
w-h-o and China not clear what the w-h-o
would get out of that but the larger
issue is is what happens to this budget
you know the u.s. is about 15 percent
half the money goes to Africa and about
40 all the 10% of the entire budget is
really going to developmental areas this
is a time when you know there has to be
more cooperation
as the needs I mean everyone's
concentrate on the US and Europe and
China but the fact is there are so many
nations India Indonesia Malaysia and
South America where they have a much
weaker health security system and in
that kind of case you could see real
dire results so yeah people are going to
regret that they were arguing about this
at this point when they see the
tragedies unfolding in the aftermath of
of the the spread of the virus from
Wuhan China has been working very hard
it's been publicly recorded that it has
been working very hard to give medical
supplies to summit in some of the
countries that you mentioned for example
is China attempting to improve its image
if you like given the fact that there
was confusion and allegations of a lack
of transparency when the virus
originally broke well I think I think
China tried its best remember this virus
was new when they developed when they
were encountering it they don't have the
the they did not have the luxury of
hindsight they didn't have two months to
react and plan and try to figure out
what their next move was yes I think
there was a bureaucratic incompetency at
the local level but when it got to the
national level and they you know decided
that this was in fact something very
serious they took immediate action and
you can see the results of that in terms
of China coming out I think it is wrong
to believe that there's some sort of
overarching conspiracy I've been living
here for 15 years I know a tremendous
number of people and both the expat and
Chinese community quite frankly I don't
know any of them I keep asking does
anybody know anybody who has it and the
answer has been uniformly no so I think
you know that's anecdotal but I can tell
you that you just don't see those signs
so it could be that there's a narrative
out there that's trying to say that
there's you know what if this happened
or what don't we know I think that is
not the point right now the world should
be focused on the incredible tragedies
that are happening and trying to prevent
more of those from happening and the
very near future one of the ways of
course to do that as everybody's agreed
is to
allow the the spread of data and
particularly the spread of information
about any new virus one of the
allegations that was made about the
local authorities in Wuhan was that they
were to some degree concerned about
giving bad news to China's central
government and that is what delayed the
process is there a lesson for the
central government and the Communist
Party to learn in terms of allowing
people to feel more comfortable about
passing on news like that well I don't
think it's necessarily just unique to
China I think all bureaucracies have a
tendency to be very very cautious they
don't want to spread bad news in terms
of China they were very quick to start
punishing many officials were removed
others have been severely disciplined
this was not something that the central
government was welcoming so when they
took over you saw a very marked
difference both an accountability and
actions that were taken but you know to
say this is a Chinese problem is kind of
like saying this is a Chinese flu you
know a pandemic is doesn't have a
nationality it moves around the world
and human nature is the same way it's
really not a good idea to try to
nationalize issues like this it's always
good to get your opinion on this I know
Tanya thank you very much indeed for
your time thank you